All right. So the learner, if the learner is choosing
which questions to ask the learner is in a distinctly more
difficult situation because it doesn't actually know what the right answer
is. So whereas the teacher could ask questions there were maximally
informative. That is to say, whittle down the hypothesis set to
one in a single question. The learner doesn't, doesn't have that
ability. The learner can't know which, what whether the question that's
being asked is going to have a yes or no answer.
So again, assuming that the learner can ask any question it wants,
but doesn't know what the right answer is. How many questions is
it going to need to ask before it can it has whittled
down the set of possible people to just the one that is
the right answer? So I gave four helpful formulae here. All in
terms of the number of people that we have to choose from.
Is, do we have to ask questions that is the size of
the set of people? Is it going to be more like the log
of size of the set of people? Since there's,
you know, lots of difference ways that the person
can be chosen. Do we have to look at two to the number of people? Or again can
the learner be as powerful as the teacher, and
get the whole thing in just a single question?
Alright, so, is, is, is this a little clearer
Charles? Can you, can you work this one through?
>> Yeah. I think I can work this one through.